that first moment sitting by myself on
an island in the Okavango Delta was the
most profound moment of my life
it is to me a wilderness beyond
comparison
the Okavango Delta is Africa's last
remaining pristine Witkin wilderness it
is an oasis in the middle of the
Kalahari Desert a sanctuary for the
incredible wildlife and biodiversity of
this region a vast patchwork mosaic of
channels floodplains lagoons and
thousands upon thousands of islands here
you can find the abundance of life all
around you the annual flood from Angola
creates these rich pastures in the Mambo
area for animals like these zebra at the
driest time of the year
alright guys so this is this is where it
starts right now is the beginning of the
expedition you've all be preparing
getting our stuff together getting our
minds right packing repacking our boats
are looking great they're floating and
this is where it all starts
this is the most most important time to
be an explorer to be a scientist working
these last wild places
what we're doing here on these
expeditions are large-scale research
transects across the Okavango Delta
we're using things like birds and fish
and aquatic insects aquatic vegetation
the habitats surrounding us wildlife
like elephants and litoris as indicators
for change across the entire system
we're on the water we have no engines
with us
you're incredibly tired your arms are in
pain shoulders your feet get very saw
your hands very sore and you find
yourself transcending them
it's like walking on water it's flowing
silent if you're silent
connected
when I'm on the macaron I watch every
report every ad everything has to be
explained every sound you're connected
to everything around you but it also
connects us to the reality of the water
everything here is water dependent
there's nothing to grab one you just
cutting them off it sometimes we are
late or unlucky and the water is gone so
we have to drag across dry land
[Applause]
now as we go deeper we go closer and
closer to the sanctuary the central
wilderness is a mambo area to my 1087
the next few days
please be present we are going to a
place where animals don't know humans
anymore it's a place that people don't
go so we have to respect this place you
have to respect the animals that are
there
you